foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody CK Coleman what it
is oh coming up today on this free
public minimal episode we're talking to
a few listeners about food clutter what
foods to subtract what foods to add for
a the most nutrient dense diet and of
course joining us in the studio today to
tackle these questions is our good
friend Dr Paul saladino yes guys thanks
for having me oh we also have an
outstanding lightning round for him as
well a bunch of different questions
where he has a minute to answer each
questions you can check those out also a
live stream question some listener tips
for you can check out the full three
hour maximal edition of episode 384
where we answer about 10 times the
questions and we dive deep into several
simple living segments that private
podcast episode is out right now if
patreon.com the minimalists your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because
advertisements suck by the way I should
mention before we start this episode
none of this should be construed as
medical advice feel free to consult your
medical doctor your astrologist your
puppy whoever you would like to consult
before uh changing anything in your life
although ultimately I think it's your
responsibility to change what you want
to change in your own life let's start
with our callers if you have a question
or comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Sarah what are
four Foods one could subtract from their
diet to live more healthfully now Paul I
selected this question first for you
mainly because and I even added the word
for because I listened to your podcast
episode which by the way Paul's podcast
is called fundamental health and I
listened to your podcast episode and I
thought it was perfect for the
minimalist because we're always thinking
about what food should I add what are
the healthy foods I'm supposed to eat
and we'll talk about that here in a
moment we have another question about
that but really
Health often involves subtraction we
figured it out with material Goods Ryan
and I aren't against all material Goods
TK when he came on board he's even
convinced us that some material goods
are really beneficial before he came on
board we were like send us an inventory
of everything you own
but Paul I want to
take an inventory of really the things
the main things that you've subtracted
from your own diet you've seen other
people that you've worked with subtract
from their diet to live more healthfully
yeah thanks for this is a great question
it's such a minimalist question when I
was thinking about this it's like this
is perfect for the show and I just want
to state from the outset that I'm not a
fruitarian so people are just not
expecting that to come later in the show
just prepare you guys but I think that
there there are two ways that I think
about how humans can live healthfully
and optimally and they're generally the
things that you add to your diet which
we'll talk about the most nutrient rich
foods and then the things that you
subtract the most toxic foods and
they're rather than four Foods I would
think of four categories of food or four
ingredients that end up in our food
supply and if you look at the way our
food supply is humans has changed over
the last 100 years or so these
ingredients have become ubiquitous
unfortunately so eliminating from your
from your them from your diet will be a
true exercise in minimalism because I
would say for most people 80 of your
pantry will go away and probably 75 to
80 of the grocery store will be things
that you do not choose to eat anymore
because you've made more intentional
choices so number one is seed oils corn
canola safflower sunflower soybean grape
seed these processed so they're refined
bleached and deodorized oils from the
seeds of plants and if you look at some
of my content on social media I've
reposted YouTube videos about how these
oils are made and basically looking at
the process of making these oils will
help people understand how bad they may
be for them intuitively because these
oils come from Siege which must be
roasted or ground then the oil is very
fragile because these seeds naturally
don't expect to be ground if we're
talking about anthropomorphization of
seeds and oils in them and then the oils
must be bleached and deodorized and
extracted with hexane because of
contaminants and so you're ending up
with a very fragile oil that gets
basically put through the ringer and
abused and you know jumped in an alley
and completely mugged and ends up being
a not very healthy food for humans and
then you know the marketing of these
oils is so confused to Consumers because
the medical community looks at them from
a very myopic perspective
and I don't want to get too technical
but we I'm a physician and so when we
look at oils for humans basically the
only metric that we want to understand
is do they raise or lower LDL and that's
probably a separate question maybe for
another podcast these oils May lower LDL
but they also raise other markers of
oxidation of LDL which are probably
better predicted of cardiovascular
health but that explains why they've
been promoted to us but getting rid of
them will then I think improve people's
cardiovascular health the cell membranes
the mitochondria
so seed oils get rid of them completely
and in favor like in a little preview
here I would I would actually favor
animal fats or fats that are much lower
in the polyunsaturated fats specifically
things like linoleic acid I don't want
to get a kind of technical but linoleic
acid is in seed oil so you want to avoid
that in high quantities and other oils
animal fats are actually much better
from that perspective second thing would
be high fructose corn syrup most people
can kind of understand this I think
within the Zeitgeist we've been told
that sugar is bad for us but there is
some Nuance around high fructose corn
syrup being different than other types
of sugar and that I think that's maybe
something else we could talk about in
the podcast I actually think that honey
especially raw organic local honey can
be quite healthy for humans there's
evidence that honey raises testosterone
which is generally a good thing for
humans and an indicator of overall
health and even in diabetics giving
people up to 125 or 150 grams of honey
per day people who have underlying
diabetes lowers fasting blood glucose
that's a lot of honey it's a lot of
honey for a diabetic and it lowers
fasting blood glucose in a week trial so
again we're talking about things to
exclude high fructose corn syrup if you
see that on a label it's it's actually a
it's a processed sugar because they
extract it from corn it's going to be
entirely glucose in order to get
fructose they have to isomerize the
glucose they have to change the
structure of the glucose molecule lots
of problems with high fructose corn
syrup the third thing maybe something
surprising for a lot of people it's
artificial sweeteners and these are
things like Splenda sucralose acek
aspartame but it even in my mind extends
to things like
um Stevia and monk fruit and um I can
talk about why in a moment but the the
more commonly known sweeteners that are
not considered natural Splenda sucralose
acek aspartame these these have some
pretty bad effects at least in animal
models aspartame has been associated
with increased anxiety behaviors which
is actually heritable between
generations of lab animals and that's at
doses that are at 15 of the FDA maximum
human dose equivalents so 15 of the
human dose equivalent of aspartame is
allowed to be given to us as humans like
per day
that creates heritable anxiety behaviors
in lab animals sucralose Splenda has
actually been studied in humans and when
combined with carbohydrates and Foods
creates an increased insulin response
increased glucose sort of in response to
meals so glucose intolerance metabolic
dysfunction so it's creating this
neurometabolic confusion in the human
body when you're eating some of these
sweeteners and your body's receiving a
signal that says the food is this sweet
in your body after hundreds of thousands
of years of human evolution expects it
to have
a certain amount of calories and it
doesn't it creates this sort of
neurological confusion and your body
doesn't know what to do in terms of the
insulin so even if we look at Stevia and
monk fruit and again this is probably
the whole podcast these appear to
interrupt the way our gut Flora
communicate so we're kind of back to the
um the preview of the next the answer or
the corollary to this question which is
what would you eat instead and I would
say for most people just use real foods
that humans have been eating for
hundreds of thousands of years and honey
is a sweetener is probably way better
the last thing is the most controversial
thing and it for me
um vegetables
do not always serve All Humans well and
the way I've tried it the way I've tried
to frame this in in my messaging is look
if you're thriving more power to you eat
a salad eat some kale eat some broccoli
but I think that there's a lot of people
out there who have
some sort of autoimmune issue some sort
of gut issue whether the gut issue is
gas bloating constipation irritable
bowel syndrome or you have some skin
issues psoriasis eczema or you have a
little bit of a mood issue or a sleep
issue or insomnia they have something
going on
and they don't find answers and they
might even dig really far they might go
see quote alternative positions but very
few Physicians I think are going to say
to a patient the spinach you're eating
might be causing your problem wow
because it's become such a part of our
culture as just a and universally
accepted benign and even more than that
like a valuable food you know a
beneficent food for humans and so if you
spinach is a good example though because
if you look at spinach it's super high
in a compound called oxalates which we
know accumulate in the human body we
make a small amount of oxalates maybe 10
milligrams a day from the breakdown of
amino acids in the human body and when
you eat even a cup and a half to two
cups of spinach you're going to seven to
ten X that amount of oxalates in your
human body because that amount of
spinach has 700 milligrams of oxalates
and you're going to absorb about 10
percent so just eating a salad at one of
these salad places in La that you think
you're doing the right thing 7x the
amount of oxalates in your body and
these compounds are the main component
of the most common type of kidney stone
for humans calcium oxalate kidney stones
they accumulate in the joints they
accumulate in our thyroids they
accumulate in breast tissue we don't
fully understand how they're
causing problems for humans but there's
clear case studies of them causing
kidney failure when people do like
smoothie cleanses and they absorb lots
of these oxalates so you can make a
smoothie
out of almonds turmeric spinach and
chocolate and those are four of the
highest oxalate containing foods and
people have done that and ended up in
honestly like on dialysis yeah I'm a
friend who has kidney stones recently
and like that it sounds like you're
describing her her diet to some extent
it's like it's a traditionally healthy
right diet right so it's so the
vegetables thing is like the way that I
would frame that is think about what
plants are trying to do on the earth
humans animals bugs we exist in in
conjunction with the plant kingdom and
we are
we're trying to live and plants are
trying to live plants have an attention
to they're alive they're trying to move
their DNA to the Next Generation and so
plants must put defense chemicals in
their leaves stems roots and seeds to
allow them to have some sort of a kind
of like Heisman strong arm to keep the
animals and insects at Bay they want to
eat them and so for some people those
defense chemicals cause problems so the
four things seed oils high fructose corn
syrup
artificial sweeteners vegetables no I'm
shocked that we're not mentioning other
things but I think they fall into some
of these categories you know the first
thing that I would think I would hear is
just processed sugar in general right
and so we hear that from virtually any
health conscious person as I've removed
processed sugar I've removed bread from
my diet you often hear I've removed
Dairy as well also maybe you could touch
uh a bit on Dairy because a lot of
people do have problems with dairy and
removing Dairy from their diet can be
really helpful but there are some
reasons they might have problems with
dairy yeah dairy's fascinating
um so
there are a lot of cultures on the
planet that drink a lot of either cow or
goat milk dairy the Maasai the samburu
these African cultures and they exist
with profound Health a lot of the
Norwegian cultures are based around
Dairy
um within the Western World We Dairy is
a very different thing there's like
different types of dairy and different
qualities of dairy that humans can eat I
think the biggest problem that most
people have is lactose intolerance and
with that I think that there are ways to
eat dairy where you have less lactose in
the dairy if you choose to include dairy
in your diet you have yogurts you have
kefirs so you'll say kefir but I
actually look this up on Google
translate because I heard the two
pronunciation so I'm pretty sure Kefir
is right
but I was over at arawan making a
smoothie with them because we're going
to do a smoothie collaboration the first
animal-based smoothie arrow on it and
even the guy that I was collaborating
with from Erawan making the Smoothie was
saying Kiefer and I'm sort of smirking
to myself thinking I know how to
pronounce this so GIF and gifs right
right yeah or portion so
so fermented dairy will reduce the
amount of lactose and goat's milk dairy
has less lactose the second Nuance you
have with milk is A1 versus A2 when
you're talking about cow's milk dairy
and this refers to the variant of casein
there are a couple of prominent proteins
in milk whey and casein and A1 casein is
a different shape of the casein protein
molecule than an A2 and it when it
breaks down is digested by the human
body it makes different molecules
specifically something called beta
caseomorphin seven when you have A1 and
that seems to be associated with some
problems in some humans so if you if you
are having a problem with dairy you
might do better with an A2 Dairy Jersey
cows Jersey cows are all A2 and or some
of the manufacturers will just say A2 on
the label I find my daughter drinks a
lot of milk but raw milk sits way better
with her is that an experience you've
had yes raw milk is really interesting
and there's a bunch of memes right now
on the internet about people getting
arrested in Canada for selling raw milk
but they can traffic like I don't know
drugs or something
it's pretty crazy
um but yeah one of the nice things about
being in La is it's easy to get raw milk
there's a couple of great farms here
that do it so when I was reintroducing
raw milk into my diet or dairy into my
diet in raw cheese and milk over the
last maybe a year and a half I did some
research and found a series of studies
which are really compelling their
observational studies which are
associations but the associations are
compelling and consistent and the
association we see is that if kids grow
up drinking raw milk and these are kids
that grow up on farms or off of farms
they have lower rates of eczema asthma
and allergies and adulthood that's
pretty cool that's awesome that's really
cool and so you could say it's
observational correlation is not
causation but it looks to be a real
correlation that's probably connected
with raw milk and some people
hypothesize that's related to
um the different bacterial organisms in
raw milk but there's other people I've
seen in the research say no it's
probably related to the Whey Protein
conformation so now we're looking at the
other protein in milk or one of the
other proteins in milk and when you heat
the Whey Protein past maybe 160 degrees
and most pasteurization processes are
heating of milk they go much Beyond 160
the confirmation of the protein changes
we know this this is what happens when
you cook an egg right you put it in a
pan the proteins change confirmation yet
goes from Clear in the white to firm in
the white and actually white right so
proteins change in conformation when we
heat them and so something about the
whey protein in cow's milk which is
what's been studied appears to be
beneficial potentially beneficial for
humans from an immunologic perspective
and you lose that when you heat the milk
so those are the things I would suggest
for people with dairy but I I I I
believe Dairy is a very powerful tool
for people and like I said these studies
that actually show significant health
benefits are compelling and if you look
at the dairy research
even deeper than this stuff there's a
lot of research that including dairy in
the diet is beneficial kids that have
more dairy fat are leaner growing up so
I think for most people including Dairy
either cow or goat sheep or camel or
something is worth considering even into
adulthood let's talk about alternative
milks oat milk rice milk almond milk
does this have to go or is this
something to include you know this is
probably something that we could
piggyback into the first question I
think it's something to get rid of for a
lot of reasons yeah
um many people you know it's funny
because when I was at arawan I had this
smoothie that we're making in a sample
and there's a woman waiting for a
smoothie at the bar and I said do you
drink cow's milk and she goes oh no she
makes this disgusted face and I'm
thinking I wonder what her story is you
know why she doesn't do that like most
of the people at arawan are looking for
these nut milks and I think that we've
for some reason we believe they're
healthier people have lactose
intolerance all the things we talked
about but if you look at the nut milks I
mean you can take oat milk as an example
um most oat milks or I mean many of the
oat milks that I've seen and done
content about contained seed oils
and glyphosates yeah well you're gonna
get you're going to get glyphosate
because they're sprayed with pesticides
and it's going to accumulate but on the
label of many prominent oat milks it
says low arusic acid rapeseed oil which
is just a kind of a a hidden name for
canola oil it's because canola is from
rape seeds and it's low aristocat that's
basically canola oil so they're they're
containing seed oils a lot of them
contain carrageenan which is a
um technically it's a sulfated
polysaccharide from algae and it is a
long molecule that is is shown pretty
clearly in animal and human studies to
cause inflammation and problems in the
human gut so a lot of these gums are
things that are in food and that you
know the list of things to exclude from
your diet could be longer than four but
you know gums are another thing you have
Jalan gums Anthem gum you have
carrageenan these are thickeners in
foods that are meant to be thick but
they aren't particularly thick to start
with some fake Greek yogurts will use
this some coffee creamers we'll use them
in their smoothies too yeah yeah it's a
thicken things and they they do appear
to be problematic for the human gut I
don't think humans were eating a ton of
a ton of algae historically and
evolutionarily um that's a whole
separate story but um so the carrageenan
ends up in these milks and then you have
the actual cons like the constituents of
the milk almonds or oats or rice or soy
most of which I think are pretty
problematic for humans we have grains
for instance and the grains are sprayed
with pesticides the grains contain
anti-nutrients these are essential
actually to seed babies of plants and so
they're going to have things like phytic
acid which is a large molecule that
chelates minerals and actually pulls
minerals out of our bodies oxalates can
do that too so almonds high in oxalates
and there's an interesting case study
it's only I think three kids but these
all three of these kids improved when
they removed almond products and the
kids had all genital urinary issues so
urinary tract infection blood in their
urine pain with urination and I think a
lot of Pediatricians see this like the
Almond products problematic for adults
and humans because of probably the
oxalates in the almonds so so nuts and
seeds in general obviously I mean when
you hear about the healthy diets one
that comes up quite often is the paleo
diet and of course compared to the
standard American diet many people
experience tremendous benefits from
something like that but they talk about
eating plants animals nuts and seeds and
you're saying well yes some plants but
we all know that intuitively like
there's a tree in front of this office
building no one goes out and starts
chewing on the bark and expects to be
nourished by it right and so there are
some plants though and we'll get to that
in a moment when we talk about the foods
to introduce into a healthy diet
um but when you look at nuts and seeds
not just the the milks or milk
Alternatives that you're consuming but
nuts and seeds themselves seem to be
problematic I think they are for a lot
of people and it's again one of these
Foods
that's colloquially considered healthy
that very few doctors will tell you to
consider as a problem for your issues
that I mean just in terms of digestion I
think so many people get better from a
digestive standpoint when they get rid
of nuts and seeds well let's just make
this clarification seeds is a is a
technical term that's correct and Grains
nuts beans and seeds colloquially are
all seeds they're all things that if you
plant them in the ground they will grow
into a plant that's a seed and it makes
sense intuitively that a plant is going
to protect its seed you can imagine this
like you know this this baby Moses or I
forget the actual historical biblical
story being cast Down the River Nile
completely unprotected that's what a
seed is it's cast out into the world and
if plants don't put some carapace on
there like a walnut or they don't put
defense chemicals in there animals are
just going to consume them
um ad-lib they'll consume as much as
they want and then all of this chance
for these plants to spread their DNA is
going to be eliminated so they do have
defense chemicals they're some of the
worst offenders I think um really
quickly with defense chemicals I hear
what you're saying about plants but I've
also heard people say that about animals
right like the whole idea of never eat
anything that tries to run away from you
could you say that animals are also
releasing some kind of Defense chemical
to prevent itself from being preyed upon
it's it's different right so
depending how the animal is slaughtered
right
um they may have cortisol but they don't
have defense chemicals in the same way
that plants do plants put these defense
chemicals in their leaves in their stems
and their seeds all the time it's not
that an animal is full of toxic things
in the liver or the muscle meat or the
blood all the time now every animal has
a life cycle right and I think that we
know that all of us are part of a cycle
of life and death and most good beef
operations I'm aware of use very very
Humane methods of of allowing the cows
to have their last day of life you know
killing the cows where they put them in
a space where the cows are not stressed
and then they use a bolt gun which is an
instant way to kill the animal and
that's been shown to have like very
little stress on the animal so I think
you of course I'm not a fan of cafos so
clustered animal feeding operations you
know like factory farming agriculture
putting animals whether it's cows or
chickens or pigs in stressful situations
not good they're going to release stress
hormone bones but they don't have the
same defense chemicals in their in their
muscles or in their organs because these
animals can run away from you because
when I talk about defense chemicals I
often say plants don't want to be eaten
and people will say well animals don't
want to be eaten either and I say well
animals have a different way to run they
run they locomote you know I haven't
seen many plants run away so they have
had to evolve these things out of
necessity I do want to talk more about
alcohol tea Cola coffee we'll get to
those in a bit but right now let's tune
into a question from Instagram Mimi
wants to know what are the four
healthiest foods to add to your diet
so really what we're talking about here
healthy most nutrient dense I added the
word four here again because I heard
your podcast about here are the four
things that I would add into a human
diet but even if you just subtract the
things that we talked about a moment ago
the seed oils the high fructose corn
syrup the artificial sweeteners and for
many people who aren't thriving veggies
or and I would say that some veggies are
probably more problematic than others
the one that they're high in oxalates
Etc but now what are we to address
Mimi's question head on what do we add
into the diet what what can I eat now
because I go to the grocery store and
you said I can't eat any of I walk
around it's like there's seed oils in
that and that and then there's high
fructose corn syrup in that and I
realize when I go to your average
grocery store I go to Sprouts or Ralphs
or most of the food in there isn't food
yeah so this is a good way to think
about it what actually is food what
things don't have labels and what things
don't need labels uh you and I think
thinking about it from the perspective
of nutrients is a good framework because
it makes it simpler for people
most of us weren't taught in elementary
school or even secondary school or
perhaps even professional school about
different micronutrients and again I
understand it's a dizzying array of
things calcium magnesium manganese
selenium K2 riboflavin Foley who knows
what all these things are needed for in
the human body but it's been a fun thing
for me to kind of
think about the nutrients that we're
aware of because there are many
nutrients that we're not even aware of
in foods that can be beneficial for
humans but of the ones we know if I know
I need this many things how do I reverse
engineer that how do I and this is a
minimalist perspective I think because I
like the Simplicity how did humans get
the most nutrient-rich food I mean we've
been a lot we've humans have been Homo
sapiens technically for 350 450 000
years before that we were Homo erectus
Homo habilis australopithecines I mean
our our genetic lineage is hominins has
been going along a long time and we
didn't have Erawan or Sprouts like it
can't be that hard how did they survive
without everyone
it cannot be that hard to to get the
nutrients that humans need to be
relatively healthy and functional and
reproductively fertile and so when you
look at the nutrients humans needs and
you think where are those concentrated
in the highest amounts the answer is
unequivocally animal foods and by animal
Foods I mean meat and organs and most of
us did not grow up eating organs so
things like liver heart bone marrow we
can get into the more exotic organs
spleen pancreas kidney testicle ovaries
brain but those are those are pretty
pretty French for most people but some
of us grew up in ethnic places
um or you know other places in the world
perhaps Eastern parts of the world where
those things were included in dishes but
most of us didn't grow up eating organs
I never grew up eating organs as a kid
other than liverwurst that was the
closest thing I got and so we if we
start with the organs which I think are
the single most nutrient rich foods on
the planet I would start with a couple
of organs so the organs that I think
humans could include in their diet that
will really change the quality of their
life by just giving you it's almost like
a video game like you just get a life
force boost you just you're not getting
these nutrients other places very easily
liver is the first one and liver is
fascinating a lot of people are not
familiar with the taste it's very it's
very irony perhaps very ferric in taste
and so there's different ways to prepare
it you can freeze it you can you can
Grill it you can get it in desiccated
capsule if you want but liver is a great
source of nutrients that a lot of people
don't get the one that I think of all
the time is I could ask you where do you
get your riboflavin and most people are
like I don't know
but the the answer as far as I can tell
is that you if you are not eating heart
and liver you're probably not getting
enough riboslavin why I don't need
riboslavin well it's part of a lot of
important process disease in the body
like energy production at the level of
mitochondria functioning of enzymatic
systems that affect hundreds of
reactions like MTHFR which is an enzyme
that some people have heard of involved
in methylation so the benefits of
riboslavin go very deep and most people
are not getting enough if they're not
eating liver and heart there are not
really any good sources of riboslavin in
the plant kingdom liver and heart are
pretty much it and then you you can go
down the list with liver it's going to
be a great source of copper to balance
iron it's going to be a good source of
things like vitamin A vitamin K2 choline
another thing that's critical for brain
and so it's just it's this powerhouse
it's this really important organ to get
and then you have heart well heart is
another good source of riboflavin if
people don't want to eat liver but heart
has coenzyme Q10 and the list goes on
and on and so the heart tastes much more
like traditional muscle meat yeah heart
is so good yeah it's tasty man but like
with liver it's funny because I've never
liked liver I mean I have that Shooters
yeah exactly so I had the I've had the
best liver and onions right and it's
really good but like after a while
you're just chewing and chewing and
chewing and it gets really dry and iron
irony and you talked me into doing the
raw liver and that is how I we liver now
like I prefer to do a roll and do those
liver Shooters than than yeah cooking up
and eat it yeah and so organs I think
are the first thing and then the meat
animal muscle meat is is similar I mean
muscle isn't organ but we think about
them colloquially as two different
things so median organs are the first
part of the the equation let me ask you
about one word uh what about tongue cow
tongue so it's it's it's a very tender
organ when you cook it in a crock pot it
has it's so good it has a unique taste
yeah I'm not familiar with any unique
benefits in terms of nutrients but um
I've just never seen any literature on
it okay yeah I'm just curious because I
love me some lingua it's yeah delicious
yeah but I will say this before we move
on from organs real quickly there's
really interesting evidence that I have
come across recently regarding the way
that organs can specifically affect the
organ the corresponding organ in the
human body so some of the most
interesting studies I've seen are giving
brain extract
phosphatidylserine from the brain of
cows to elderly people who have
cognitive decline and it improves their
cognitive function and this is wild
right they've tried to do the same thing
with plant derived hospital serine it
doesn't work because phosphatidylserine
from animals is different than
phosphatidylserine from plants so you
have brain extract from cows improving
the cognitive function of humans you see
the same thing with thymus which is an
organ that very few of us remember but
it's a it's an immune organ that sits
behind the sternum that regresses it
involutes as we age but in both animal
and human trials when you give thymic
extracts the thymus begins to grow again
and in kids in human kids they get less
respiratory tract infections when you
give them an immune organ it's really
interesting stuff yeah it's really wild
to see how deep kind of the the sort of
I don't know the evolutionary parallels
go with these organs and then yeah now
what do you say to people because you're
talking right now about adding in a lot
of animal products and a lot of people
out there who are vegans or vegetarians
and some of them are really thriving on
that we have a friend Dr Joanne
Cacciatore who's been a vegan she runs a
farm from by 28 years and you could tell
she's just thriving and so it may be
that for some people for whatever reason
she's able to digest and make
bioavailable the nutrients that are in
Plants better than someone else who is
struggling with a vegan diet it's
possible it's possible I think there are
I've seen you know there's
there's a lot of people who benefit from
vegan diets I think for a variety of
reasons perhaps it's cutting out the
processed foods
um and then I've seen a lot of people
sadly really benefit for a few years and
then get very bad yeah um I've had a
couple people on my podcast who were
vegans and depression autoimmune issues
so I think there's something there that
we don't fully understand there are
cases
um I might characterize them as outliers
of people who are vegans and quote
unquote thriving but the majority people
that I've seen and worked with and
perhaps I have a confirmation bias but I
do come in contact with a lot of people
don't do well without animal products
for more than two or three years well I
think that makes sense because what you
were talking earlier we've evolved over
about three to four maybe more than four
million years since we climbed out of
trees and started looking around and
saying what else is there to eat we've
evolved eating animals now just because
something is natural doesn't mean that
it is the most appropriate thing to do
right we do things that are not natural
it's how I drove a car down here right
my ancestors didn't drive a car down
here the uh and so but it doesn't mean
that it's wrong to do that necessarily
right it may be the most appropriate
thing it's way better than walking the
76 miles down here once a week and so
um for some people they thrive on that
diet just like I think of my wife she
has a very similar diet to yours but she
eats some vegetables and is thriving on
that right and she's like just as fit as
you as well so like I think part of it
is like that she's exercising all the
time similar to you and she's able to
take in these calories and use them but
she also doesn't have the digestive
issues that someone like me has I've got
an autoimmune condition that I can't
barely eat anything especially certain
vegetables so if I eat a sweet potato
um if I eat an entire sweet potato it
feels like my ankles are broken and it's
like oh wow that's probably oxalates
yeah yeah I think so but even white
potatoes will do the Excellence in there
too yeah yeah I know
um but and so a lot of oxalate rich
foods with will harm my digestion
because I have leaky gut or or you know
the tight junctions of my mucosal layer
are are compromised isn't it possible
too though like if you cut out every
single oxalate in your diet right now
like isn't there there could be an
adverse effect by just cutting them all
out all out together right is that true
yeah so some people experience a um a
dumping syndrome it's an oxalate dumping
yeah yeah it's an interesting thing and
it's it's
I think clinically it's the body saying
okay we're ready to get rid of these and
all of them come out at once oh yeah so
you get kidney stones and some people
get kidney stones some people get rashes
I mean it's not bad for everyone but I
have heard anecdotally of things
happening and so yeah the recommendation
for people and we can't really know this
because Western medicine has never
explored this is perhaps eat a little
bit of oxalate you know don't eat 700
milligrams a day but maybe 100
milligrams of oxalates per day which
allows a little bit of sweet potato or
you know maybe half a kiwi because kiwi
actually has some oxalates in the fruit
you know you can look at the high
oxalate foods and you can still eat some
foods that are moderate oxalates as you
kind of do the transition yeah when I
found out chocolate was high in oxalates
I was I was so angry I was depressed for
three weeks
which just cause them to eat more
chocolate yeah so I can eat I can eat
anything man like I am really lucky I
can digest anything like give me a
bucket of nails and it will hurt going
down but I could get them down and be
fine but they'll make a perfect poop
but the problem is like my um I got skin
issues you talked about Eczema and
psoriasis I haven't been like diagnosed
with it but um I know that uh if I eat
dates if I eat even eggs like I get this
you know anti or this an inflammatory
reaction on my face where like I get
Little Beard dander if I get you know my
scalp gets dry and stuff it's crazy save
that for the autoimmune question we'll
double back on that but I wanted to talk
about the two other foods to add in here
we already talked about organs and
animal protein from meat Dairy eggs but
then there's certain carbohydrates that
you're now okay with yeah this has been
the main transition from carnivore Paul
that was here perhaps the last time and
yeah it's it's fun to do these Journeys
and to try to to face my own inner
dogmatism and to not really succumb to
audience capture and these sorts of
things but what I learned after about a
year and a half two years on a strict
carnivore diet of just meat organs and
fat was that long-term ketosis didn't
work well for me and now I've realized
that it doesn't work for a lot of people
um and so I added back in carbohydrates
fruit first honey and then fruit and
that helped with a lot of that stuff for
a variety of reasons I think that
um there are perhaps a few vitamins and
minerals that are a little easier to get
in Fruit than they are in meat but I
think the majority of it is just that
human physiology works well when we have
carbohydrates and thinking about it from
an anthropologic perspective I really
believe that the best characterization
of this that I've that I've come up with
or seen is that fruit and carbohydrates
well let's just say carbohydrates and
humans are a signal of abundance
historically evolutionarily if
carbohydrates were available it was
usually spring and summer if we're
living by the equator which is where we
believe humans evolved we had spring and
summer most of the year so we had
abundance but as we moved away from the
equator carbohydrates become more and
more a clear signal of abundance and
that connects with human fertility and
human thriving and so the molecular
mechanisms behind this are consistent in
humans when we eat carbohydrates the the
body says it kind of breathes the sigh
of relief and goes okay now it's time to
reproduce now it's time to get out in
the sun and lift rocks and Hunt things
and and be to be a thriving human when
we don't have carbohydrates we're in
this metaphorical winter where we're
kind of thinking this is not the time to
have babies and this is maybe the time
to kind of huddle together and to store
our food and not necessarily do things
that are large energy expenditures so I
think that for most humans
having carbohydrates in your diet year
round which is another Nuance of the
discussion is a beneficial thing because
we see improvements in hormones
connected with this abundance we see
decreasing levels of something called
sex hormone binding globulin which
allows more free hormones specifically
estrogen and testosterone and women and
men respectively we see better
electrolytes we know that insulin
signaling at the level of the kidney
insulin being this peptide hormone
released when we eat protein or
carbohydrates but mostly carbohydrates
so it's released from the pancreas and
it has many roles in the human body most
of which I believe are very beneficial
and some is critical for life though it
gets a bad rap but at the level of the
kidney it gives this signal hay can
serve sodium and with the Sodium there's
all these importers and antiporters and
the different tubules of the kidney come
other minerals come other electrolytes
see things like calcium things like
potassium things like chloride things
like magnesium that allow muscles to
work well so after a year and a half on
a carnivore diet I'm in the climbing gym
and every time I tense my arm to hold
hold I get a cramp in my forearm or I
get a cramp in my calf and many people
have experienced this on ketogenic diets
they just can't even stretch their legs
in the morning because they'll get this
lightning calf cramp and that's an
electrolyte abnormality that is really
not able to be remedied even with
Herculean or massive amounts of salt
some people are eating 20 plus grams of
sodium chloride or sea salt on a keto
diet in the effort to like manage their
electrolytes and it's just not that to
me is just um you know like just really
trying to put a square peg in a round
hole it doesn't work
you mentioned that uh long-term ketosis
doesn't really do good for you and for a
lot of people I know when some people on
ketosis talk about carbs they they speak
of carb cycling or only eating fruits
during uh periods of intermittent
fasting do you have a schedule for when
you do this or is it you'll have steak
and bananas at the same time I'll eat
them at the same time and so the
arguments for
separating your carbohydrates and your
your meat are generally around something
called the Randall cycle which is a bit
technical but what we know is that
the the human body likes to do either
one fuel or another it's like we have a
gas hybrid car in the human body and
it's only going to do gas or electric
that's the sort of that's the canonical
thinking but we can do a little bit of
mix of both and so people will say that
according to the Randall cycle if you
eat fat with carbohydrates your body
can't burn both and you're going to
store the fat because it's going to
preference the carbohydrates but what we
know at a deeper level is that if you're
eating saturated fats with the
carbohydrates that doesn't seem to
create this
um this competition as much as
polyunsaturated fats so now we're back
to polyunsaturated fats and Seed oils
being problematic so polyunsaturated
fats are probably the biggest issue with
the Randall cycle in terms of competing
things so if you eat if you're eating
polyunsaturated fats with carbohydrates
that may affect this sort of
um this sort of railroad track uh
conundrum that we run into we can only
burn one of these at a time and you're
going to store the other one type of
thing but in in me and the people I've
worked with I don't see any issue eating
carbohydrates with meat or fruit like
meat or fat or any of these things I
think it it results in no metabolic
issues it's something that we would have
done evolutionarily like when I was with
ahaza in Tanzania which I think is
something I did since last time I was
here
um you know we're out hunting and we get
an animal and the next thing they do
they're climbing a tree to get a beehive
and they're handing me a piece of
honeycomb as they're handing me a piece
of liver right that we cooked on an open
fire so yeah it's happening at the same
time there's never this like oh I need
to eat this and then I need to eat this
I think that if you really look at the
the biochemistry at a at a granular
level there's not a real problem there
for most people so your banana and steak
smoothies are totally okay it's totally
okay
well I guess you have to pay a lot of
attention to how you're preparing those
saturated fats right because going out
to restaurants today and buying them a
lot of them are cooked and some of the
oils you're you're telling us yeah so
one of the most fun things that I do now
with my content is this I call it like
Health journalism and I put on the mic
and my buddy's kind of filming me
surreptitiously like he's being kind of
subtle in the background and we walk
into restaurants and I go I have a food
allergy can you tell me what your food
is cooked in and it's interesting
understanding what's happening there and
most restaurants are cooking in seed
oils they're using corn or Canola or
soybean or safflower and most of them
are doing it thinking that they're doing
it correctly I mean Chick-fil-A uses
peanut and on their website they say
peanut oil is healthy for humans it's
heart healthy again it goes back to this
thing that we talked about earlier it
may lower LDL but then it raises the
oxidized form like the broken down sort
of oxidized really atherosclerotic form
of LDL but most of these businesses
don't understand and the consumer demand
has been polyunsaturated oils because
that's what we've been told is healthy
for the last really the last 50 to 70
years but especially in the last 30
years McDonald's used to use Tallow in
their fryers yeah it's just like 92 or
something which is rendered beef fat and
is very healthy for humans it contains
stearic acid which is an 18 carbon
saturated fat that is very beneficial
for our mitochondria and healthy for
humans and then we'll switch to peanut
or I think they use sunflower or
safflower now because the consumer
demand it was driven by this one I
forget his name but there was this very
rich man who got heart disease and
blamed it on the Tallow for from
McDonald's I'm not sure how he made the
causal connection but he he was you know
he wasn't he was really instrumental in
getting them to switch and so now people
think it's more beneficial so a lot of
restaurants are cooking in that stuff
how do you feel about other meats like
chicken pork
um so this gets a little nuanced at the
highest level I think if you're eating
animal meat it's going to be very
nutritious for humans and it's going to
result in Better Health and it's going
to get you a lot of the nutrients that
you're not always going to get if you're
eating exclusively plant foods but if
you take it a level deeper you find that
beef or ruminants things like deer or
elk or lamb are it's they eat a diet
that is ancestrally or evolutionarily
consistent because they're fat on grass
but it's very hard to get a properly fed
chicken right because almost no chickens
in the United States are fed bugs and
bugs and worms and leaves they just they
have to be fed grains yeah but chickens
don't eat grains in the wild so
essentially we have nearly 100 of all
chickens which make all the eggs and
chicken meat that we're eating who are
grain-fed like the equivalent of a
grain-fed cow versus a grass-fed cow
okay and pork is the same way wild uh
wild pigs will root and eat roots and
bugs and worms or little they'll eat
little animals I mean they'll eat little
like Mal mice and rats and things like
that so that's like a that's a real diet
for a pig but that's not what they're
feeding them in feedlots they're feeding
them grains and they're mostly feeding
them corn and soy so what happens with
monogastric animals and humans are a
monogastric animal in distinction to a
ruminant animal with multiple stomachs
we have one stomach monogastric animals
cannot get rid of polyunsaturated fatty
acids easily so if you feed a chicken or
you feed a pig corn and soy they
accumulate polyunsaturated fats in their
cell membranes oh wow which means their
fat content increases in this
polyunsaturated fat this linoleic acid
particularly that we find in seed oils
that I think is harmful for humans at
evolutionarily inconsistent levels so if
you look at a wild chicken or a wild pig
four to five linoleic acid in the fat a
domestically raised chicken or Pig 15 to
20 linoleic acid and they're fat and
just for comparison canola oil 20 to 25
linoleic acid a soybean oil 55 linoleic
acid grapeseed oil 65 linoleic acid
that's why seed oils I think one of the
reasons they're so harmful for humans
Tallow two percent linoleic acid butter
two percent linoleic acid ghee two
percent linoleic acid so
I think people could run into problems
eating lots of bacon right yeah you have
a very fatty no not bacon too right it's
like fresh chocolate now bacon like
chocolate covered bacon yeah right they
have bacon flavored chocolate bars they
do yeah um I'm sure they sell them at
everyone for 25. exactly like okay
milkshake yeah right but like you know
what you do like
like it's not as big a deal as what you
do consistently yeah like so like bacon
every once in a while probably not a big
deal
um chocolate every once in a while
probably not a big deal unless you have
bad kidney stones or Joshua's ankles
right yeah um
but you know like making it the majority
of your diet is probably not a great
idea because of we're ultimately what
we're thinking about is membrane Health
at the level of cells mitochondria the
nuclear membranes all these type of
things we're kind of like acid yeah that
makes sense yeah it doesn't make a
little technical I'm sorry Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the Lightning Run where we
answer your questions from Tick Tock yes
indeed you can follow the minimalist on
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter
at the minimalist we'll put links to Dr
Paul saladino's Handles in the show
notes as well over at the
minimalists.com podcast now Paul
generally what we do here is we answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we call the
minimal maxims they're in the show notes
so people can copy and share or pithy
answers on social media media but this
time we're doing something a little
special we have several lightning round
questions for you so Ryan TK and I we're
just going to step back and let you do
your thing you'll have 60 seconds and if
you go over time Professor Sean will
give you the gong and Jordan will drag
you out of the studio before before we
start imprompter requests is there a way
I can get in uh three additional
lightning round questions yeah why not
sure actually let's save those for the
talk aboutables on the private podcast
sounds good sounds good there we go all
right first question here Ruby
why isn't the vegan diet optimal for
human health no fear of the time okay I
was going to say the timer starts what
are you reading the question give me
those three seconds back
the vegan diet is not optimal for human
health because it lacks so many of the
nutrients that are found exclusively in
animal Foods they generally start with
the letter c though that's just an easy
way to remember them creatine carnitine
choline then we get to the other Seas
the Nazis answering taurine vitamin K2
B12 it riboflavin it that you need these
nutrients to thrive as a human we've
been eating animals throughout our
history I believe animals and eating
them was one of the key events that
allowed us to become human we see this
incredible increase in brain growth size
about two million years ago when we
started hunting more it's a correlation
but it's quite compelling so I think the
vegan diet is not optimal for most
humans because it is both deficient in
the key nutrients that allow us to
thrive and it allows and it results in a
large load of toxins like we talked
about so you're concentrating the toxins
and you're getting the least
nutrient-rich foods but if someone is
thriving on that diet you're not telling
them they should change anything I'm
commanding you to do anything it's
simply if you're struggling with it if
you're struggling with it consider the
fact become curious and and understand
there are other ideas that that um are
there other options that might result in
health another question from Horus
if you could eat only the same meal for
the rest of your life what would it be
oh great question I actually thought
about this last night as I was eating
most of this meal so my favorite steak
is a sirloin flap steak it's delicious
if you guys haven't had it I'm gonna eat
it with some frozen raw liver a little
bit of um heart
um I mean I guess this question's so
easy because I could just have a
colossal meal right I need to have a
little bit of thymus in there too and
then for um carbohydrates I'm going to
eat some fruit or some fruit juice I
really like making fresh greased orange
juice these days now how is that
ancestrally consistent orange juice
you're in my 60 seconds
how do the rules work here
so we get orange juice and then uh I'm
gonna have some Dairy because I love it
I'm either gonna have some raw milk
either cow or goat and a little bit of
honey and maple syrup it's probably
gonna be my meal nice nice still under
16. this is about 15 seconds to respond
to the interloper
that was a LeBron move by the way you
knocked away the ball you blocked the
first shot attempt and he still drinks
uh I think that we see that cultures
make things like we we do process foods
within cultures historically
evolutionary cultures process things
they grind grains they
um they they do they milk animals they
will make juice out of things to remove
the fibers and so I think that
um people would say oh that's so many
oranges you're drinking five oranges
yeah it's delicious and I love it and
I'm still insulin sensitive and so
someone though who struggles with uh
fungal overgrowth in their intestines
they may struggle with something like
they may it's the context we talked
about earlier right I don't think the
orange juice is causing that fix the
root cause and let's just add this for
people as a little bit more of a of
something to think about
ask the question what is causing this
fungal overgrowth right people want to
believe or we there has been this idea
this ethos that that fruit is causing
Canada and that's just not true that's
not the case it is dysbiosis it's
probably coming from something else in
your diet that is causing the candidate
to overgrow candida candida whatever
um and so find the root cause correct
that if you have sibo and you have a
motility issue figure out what is
triggering that immune reaction against
your neurologic system in your gut the
fruit isn't causing it and the goal is
to be able to help people improve the
the basically the variety of their diet
eventually this is different than I used
to think and this is kind of a fun thing
like I'll say this I want people to be
able to eat as many foods as possible
and sometimes eliminating Foods
temporarily is very powerful and then
getting them back is a celebration
another question from Lillian steal my
time
what's wrong with tap water and what
kind of water do you drink now before
you answer that
placed in front of Dr Paul Saladin right
now is uh Mountain Valley Flat Water
Cheers Cheers oh I'm out of I'm out um
Alabama but um
tap water is a bit of a problem
60 seconds go so if you go to the
environmental working group they have a
really great database of the analysis of
tap Waters where you are and you can see
what's in the tap waters for most cities
Austin Los Angeles wherever it's 70 to
200 contaminants on the order of
pesticides organic solvents used in
industry known carcinogens birth control
hormones other pharmaceutical drugs uh
and that's not that's not counting
potentially problematic things with
fluoride and drinking water which is
quite a controversial thing chlorine
used in the water to sterilize it in
chlorine derivatives so tap water is a
nightmare be intentional with your water
you can also go to most of the water
companies Mountain Valley is a great one
I don't have any affiliation I don't
know if you guys do they have on their
website they have on their website a an
actual download of the certificate of
analysis and there's nothing really bad
in non Valley so that's great but test
the water that you're drinking know what
the COA is I usually drink Mountain
Valley when I'm in the states in Costa
Rica I drink coconut water yeah from
coconuts oh wow that's great and also
reverse osmosis is an option so we'll
put a link to the
ewg.org tap I believe it is I first
learned about that from you and it
terrified me enough to make sure that I
have a reverse osmosis filter uh in my
kitchen because any drinking water I
have at home I don't want it to be
contaminated so I'll put a link to the
reverse osmosis thing that I use as well
I just want to say if you use that link
just be prepared to be freaked out a
little bit because it's not a matter of
how much of this is in your drinking or
if this is in your drinking water it's a
matter of how much so like no matter
where you go I remember we grew up in
Hamilton County near Hamilton County in
Ohio and it had like the best drinking
water in the whole country still crazy
amount of contaminants in it yeah yeah
and it's terrifying uranium sometimes is
in the drinking water
another question here make a comment
about the version osmosis before you go
for it um some people when I say that I
use reverse osmosis because you can get
a countertop reverse osmosis it's very
easy you don't have to put the whole
thing under the sink and hire a plumber
you can get a countertop reverse osmosis
on Amazon and and it's great it seems to
work really well some people say what
about the minerals and I think two
things I think you can re-mineralize it
pretty easily and if you're eating a
diet that's nutrient Rich you probably
don't need to remineralize your water um
depending how much you're drinking but
if you're worried about minerals in your
Ro just remineralize it or just eat
nutrient-rich Foods Yeah question here
from Valentina besides diet what are
three ancestral activities that would
improve the average person's life
okay here we go so I think that most of
these for me are around circadian
rhythms and sleep and it's
avoiding blue light at night sleeping at
a consistent schedule one of the things
I've noticed living at the equator is
that the sun sets and Rises about the
same time every day so I have a
consistent bedtime and a consistent
waking time and if you're anywhere in
the world that's going to change very
slowly throughout the world like if
you're far from the equator so I think a
consistent bad time a consistent waking
time light in the eyes first thing in
the morning and then avoidance of
artificial light at night those are
really critical things for me along with
grounding perhaps which I think is very
underrated and very hard to do in a lot
of cities being in Los Angeles it's been
a real challenge to ground I can't just
walk around and bare feet
um in arawan and I won't get grounded if
I'm there anyway so I have to find a
patch of grass sit there and bare feet
and there's surprising amount of good
evidence with grounding so grounding
plus really controlling your sleep
cycles similar bedtime similar waking
and light in the eyes in the morning
really helps set the Circadian rhythm
dude you would totally fit into air one
with with bare feet but there's no
grounding mat no that's true but you
would not be able to blame it you're
Seated on a grounding mat right now so I
saw him I tripped over the wires that's
that's actually our explosive booby trap
you can check out our grounding episode
we did with uh Clint over uh amazing
episode people absolutely love that
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well Jeffrey has a question for
us what are the three most common
environmental toxins in our lives today
this is a tough one in 60 seconds I
think I'm going to start with
xenoestrogens things like phthalates
parabens
um it's in Plastics and they're
everywhere so you
um you go to the Starbucks and you get a
coffee which I'm not a fan of and I
think we're going to talk about that and
that coffee that plastic coffee cup is
lined with plastic that that paper
coffee cup is lined with plastic and
that coffee plastic has pfas para floral
alkylated substances in it the butcher
paper they use at Whole Foods and I
haven't figured out a great workaround
for this the butcher paper they use at
Whole Foods for my meat has plastic on
the inside which could have xenome
estrogens and pfas every can you're
using even if it's bpa-free has
xenoestrogen compounds in it because
there's BPS and bpe every soda you're
drinking everything in a can even things
in a box boxed water box coconut uh
water are lined with plastic and that
plastic contains compounds that are
going to mimic estrogen or be endocrine
disruptors in the human body and that
was just the first one give them a bonus
minute please so then we have then you
might have glyphosate the pesticides
those are everywhere and then I think
um yeah we could probably just stop
there those are the big ones I think if
you're if you're plastic and glyphosate
you're getting the big ones but I think
that it's just it just goes back to
avoid avoid Plastics as much as you can
don't drink water out of plastic think
about the things your food is packaged
in and I can't avoid it I'm not perfect
in this most meat comes in packaged in
plastic but if you minimize then you'll
be getting a lower dose of these things
yeah we have a couple questions from
Tammy what's her first question here can
I still be healthy if I drink coffee you
better say yes
does my time start when I start talking
or oh sorry you're out of time Paul
I wish we could go into that further
I think that I think you can be right
it's kind of like we talked about a
little bit of bacon a little bit of
chocolate a little bit of coffee not a
big deal I will say this the quarter
life of caffeine is 12 hours which means
that if you drink coffee at eight
o'clock in the morning and you're
drinking one cup you're getting 200
milligrams of caffeine and that 200
milligrams is going to equal 50
milligrams 12 hours later that's what a
quarter life means oh wow okay so you
have 50 milligrams of caffeine in your
bloodstream at 8 pm that is going to
affect your sleep cycles without a doubt
now if you're drinking two cups or some
of the my compatriots are drinking
coffee at 11 o'clock right in the
morning right now so you're going to
have a quarter of the caffeine in your
current coffee 12 hours later so I worry
that as a society we are chronically
disrupting our sleep cycles with coffee
that's probably the biggest problem that
we have and that's just the beginning
what about energy drinks what we're
using at the gym at 2 p.m in the
afternoon right pre-workouts that we're
using at the gym at 4 pm or 6 p.m so
it's just sleep cycles are getting are
really getting besieged today it's so
it's so weird like you have people like
Josh and my grandmother who are too the
same I mean I'm just kidding no but but
they can drink coffee and go to sleep
like that I just I wonder if we put if
we put you in a sleep lab would your
sleep architecture be different when
you're doing that yeah it would actually
be better with drinking coffee night but
I think that's because I'm so dependent
on it I'll tell you I can drink coffee
at 8pm and go to bed at 8 30 and no
problem but if I don't drink coffee at
night my sleep score tracked with my
aura ring suffers and I'm not so I'm not
suggesting that anyone they should go
out and drink coffee what I'm saying is
that I'm so dependent on it there's
something my body is telling me that hey
you need this essential nutrient
in order to sleep yeah anyway we got one
more question from Tammy here what about
olive oil and vinegar
so um vinegar I don't really have any
problems with know what's in your
vinegar some vinegars are better than
others and can have contaminants but I
think vinegar is great although I think
it can erode the tooth enamel if you
drink too much of it because it's quite
acidic olive oil is made from the fruit
of Olives not the seeds so in general
it's much better than a seed oil but if
you look at the amount of linoleic acid
and olive oil it's between 5 and 17 so
you're still getting a more olive oil
than you would in animal fat so I'm a
fan of animal fats over olive oil I
would never cook with olive oil I met a
guy the other day in arawan he said can
I cook with olive oil no don't heat
olive oil it's unstable you don't want
to heat the olive oil because you're
going to oxidize the fats if you want to
heat an oil use something like Tallow or
butter or ghee those are much better
fats to heat in my strong belief so
olive oil is okay if you want a liquid
oil and the only time I could think of
someone using liquid oil is if they're
eating a salad but you guys know how I
feel about salads so olive oil better
than seed oils know the quality a lot of
oil is also cut with seed oils and can
have impurities I'm going to go over on
this one because it's really important
point if the olive oil is not cold
pressed extra virgin organic you don't
want it what about coconut oil coconut
oil is great it's not an animal fat but
it's the it's my favorite plant fat so
it's very low linoleic acid and I think
it has a lot of great qualities it's
good to cook with but again I would
choose Tallow butter or ghee because
you're going to get vitamin K2 vitamin E
vitamin A stearic acid like animal
nutrients and the fat yeah I'm going to
save the sunscreen question for the
private podcast coming up here in a
moment we'll get to all of TK's question
Alabama has some questions the private
podcast patrons they are in the live
stream right now they got a bunch of
questions I think Danny is even over
there jumping up with some questions so
we have so many more questions for you
Dr saladino you can check out his
podcast it's called the fundamental
Health podcast uh real quick uh for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist you know we're talking about
decluttering your food but you know you
can also declutter your screens
so uh Ryan and I a few years ago we came
up with these seven minimalist
wallpapers because whenever we do
anything it's steeped in irony so we
can't have a minimalist wallpaper there
are seven minimalist wallpapers for your
phones for your desktop collect all
seven
are you technically have to you download
you get one file we'll send you all
seven for free you can find them over on
our resources page over at the
minimalists.com resources you can
download all seven minimalist wallpapers
there's one the five questions to ask
before buying that's my favorite because
you put it on your your phone screen and
you're at the checkout line getting
ready to make that impulse buy maybe at
air one for the 47 smoothie and you're
like okay here are the five questions I
need to ask before I buy this thing but
it's especially helpful you have it on
your desktop and you're getting ready to
buy you're getting an Impulse buy a
reverse osmosis filter on Amazon here
are the five questions to ask right here
on my screen it's a constant reminder so
if you want to simplify your smartphone
screen or your desktop head on over to
the minimalists.com click on the
resources tab there you'll see a bunch
of free resources including our seven
minimalist wallpapers for your
smartphone and desktop I'm Alabama I
want to check in with that live stream
do you have a comment for us right now
we sure do we have a comment here from
Nastasia she says I love all of Dr Paul
saladino's mini reels about seed oils
What to eat and what to avoid how to
shop at grocery stores Etc super helpful
yeah you know what was so freeing for me
Paul
was when I started eating this wigs I
eat relatively healthfully before I say
relatively right but it was causing a
lot of issues a lot of oxalates and the
smoothies and all the stuff that I was
eating was causing all this indigestion
and and
just upset in my stomach it was really
freeing when I walk into a grocery store
now and I look around I realize like oh
I can't eat any of this yeah and that it
eliminates all the sort of decision
fatigue because I simply know none of
this is for me or at least 95 of it is
not for me and it gives me that freedom
to move forward and actually get the
things for my body that are nourishing
that make me feel healthy I remember
when we were living I remember when we
were living in Montana like Josh
challenged himself to eat like a bag of
spinach every single day I used to carry
around pocket greens he really did great
patrons will get back into your live
stream in a moment but first from
Alabama what do you got for us here's a
minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hey guys my name is Jenny and I'm
calling from Sheboygan Wisconsin I
wanted to share a tip and trick with a
minimalists that have a family my
husband and I recently became a family
of three welcome their son Micah end of
the world six months ago and adding
another being to our lives is going to
add a great deal of physical items and
items that are outgrown really quickly
to honor our families minimalism efforts
and living within our one family income
needs we met
um and went to a family member who has a
son when you're older than our son Micah
we asked them if we could borrow their
baby clothes and toys that they were
storing in their basement and bins just
in case they had another baby boy so we
thought that we could use them now
rather than them just collecting dust in
their basement we have saved a great
deal of time and money by borrowing
these items and in turn we're storing
them in our basement as a family has a
smaller home and doesn't have that space
and they didn't want to pay to rent a
space
we have even started buying their
clothes and gifting them to the family
member as they will become ours in the
future when our son goes into that size
so we're creating this baby boy clothes
moving wardrobe and getting the most out
of each item by sharing them with
multiple families this could work with
family members or friends co-workers of
any listeners
um that need a tip it's a win-win for
everybody
all right y'all that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 384 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
why did Paul finally let go of his
carnivore dogma and become an omnivore
again
what are the roles of stress and Trauma
in the gut microbiome and in disease
plus we got a million more questions for
Dr saladino and the minimalists also
this week we've got our obsolete objects
segment three obsolete kitchen items I
think we maybe even talked about more
than three there we've got an
outstanding added value segment for you
as well and much much more of less and
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode 0
0.01 big thanks to Dr Paul saladino for
joining us today you can check out his
podcast it is called fundamental Health
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes and you can check him out at
carnivoremd.com some free resources over
there we'll put a link to all of his
social media in the show notes as well
over at the minimalists.com podcast and
if you leave here today with just one
message please let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign